hello everybody
and welcome to the reuben report direct
message i
am dave rubin today is april 15 2021 and
we are doing
a live ask me anything q a from the
reubenreport.locals.com
community as always subscribe click that
notification button and i just want to
get one thing out right at the top of
the show i am
seriously in a mood today like what was
i doing five minutes ago i was literally
googling
punching bags and i asked people on
twitter where i can get a good punching
bag because there is
so much endless
bull being fed to us
at such an extraordinary and
increasingly
fast level that we got a real problem on
our hands between the democrats today
trying to pack the courts
and dc is going to be the 51st state and
now pfizer says you'll need a third shot
and just like the endless nonsense
that is being pushed on us and i just
watched a minute ago
we'll hold it till next week i guess but
uh fauci
that faucist was uh you know doing a
congressional panel because that's all
these people do they don't do actual
work
they just do congressional panels and
and media appearances and jim jordan was
just grilling him on when will the
numbers be low enough so we can go back
to normal when will the numbers and
fouchy will just not
give a number and then that really awful
human being
gavin newsom my governor here in
california said today that everyone over
16 can now get the vaccination
and yet still and i tweeted this at him
still today which is april 15th
he still will not open the state until
june 15th
so even though he's going on and on
about how we can all be vaccinated the
weather's obviously great it's the
spring here
in california well still we're not going
to open up for an
arbitrary two months you think that has
something to do with the recall we'll
get to that in a minute anyway so i am
just
in a mood today like i want to punch
someone and i just apologize in advance
and
michael we told you the other day he was
a little drunk on his birthday fell out
of a car he's in a boot
no no not drunk not drunk just kidding
but he was in a the point is he's in a
boot he was completely sober and uh he's
in a boot oh
all right that's tough that's tough uh
anyway guys uh
i want to do one story before we get to
the uh to the q a
uh because this supreme court packing
thing is just absolutely insane now
remember
during the election remember that donald
trump first joe biden election
uh joe biden was asked many times does
he plan to pack the court and by packing
the court that means expanding the
amount of justices
on the court not getting a make-up of a
court like you want meaning
you know a judge steps down or a judge
dies or something like that and then
putting on a court
putting on a justice by going through
the proper measures okay
and we can we can argue about all the
political parts of how that happens how
it's become completely partisan all that
but packing the court meaning expanding
the amount of judges
so that in essence you can always get
results that you want well joe biden
never would answer the question but it
was very obvious that he was going to do
this and it's also very obvious that joe
biden
ain't in charge of anything so i've got
two quotes here
and then we're going to show you some
video of the penguin from batman
this is first from the intercept the
bill would add four seats
to the high court bringing the total to
13 from the current nine
the bill is led by house judiciary
committee chair
jerry nadler the penguin subcommittee
chair hank
johnson and freshman representative
mondaire jones
in the senate the bill is being
championed by ed markey
of massachusetts so that's the intercept
which is pretty lefty and here's the
daily wire which obviously is a little
more on the right
the legislation comes after democrat
president joe biden announced last week
that he had created a commission
to study court packing a political move
that is so controversial
that the majority of americans oppose it
because according to the new york times
he was under pressure from activists
before last year's election biden said
that voters did not deserve to know his
stance
on packing the courts okay so we're
going to show you some video of jerry
nadler
in just a second but just really really
clear to what's going on here
we knew they were going to do this the
media just did not push him enough
joe biden is not in charge it's very
obvious that this is the radical lefties
that are in charge of the administration
and just
listen guys let's just say it as it is
this is a
massive brazen assault by
in essence two branches of government on
another branch we have separation powers
we have three branches of government
right we have the executive branch they
sign things into law that's the
president we have the legislative branch
they're the ones that are supposed to
write laws
they don't really do it they're not very
good at it and then we have the judicial
branch they make sure that everything is
legal
these things are separate and they have
checks and balances so no
one branch or one person gets too
powerful well now in essence you have
the executive branch the president
working with the legislative branch
congress
to override the ability for the judicial
branch to be
impartial and and also one other thing
before
this nadler clip do you think that if
they had the makeup of the court that
they like do you think if the court
leaned more liberal blue whatever you
want to call it left
do you think they'd be doing this of
course not so this is an
absolute assault on every
american norm like this is it if that
branch of government is taken out which
is what they're trying to do
experiment over people experiment over
but let's listen
to the penguin uh jerry nadler the
overwhelming majority of cases
don't get considered by the supreme
court which they are entitled to do
and throughout much of our history did
our predecessors made eminent sense when
they
rigged when they pegged the size of the
supreme court to the number of judicial
circuits
as our country has grown so too to the
supreme court
13 justices for 13 circuits is a logical
progression
and that is another reason why i'm glad
to join
my colleagues in introducing the
judiciary act
of 2021 to establish the supreme court
size
as 13. uh that's a nice number it
matches it's not a nice number it's it's
a it's a it's a proper number it matches
the number of circuits
as it has historically and it also will
enable us
to do justice and to rectify the great
injustice
that was done in packing the court and
some people will say we're packing the
court we're not packing it we're
unpacking it
senator mcconnell and the republicans
packed the court over the last couple of
years
as senator uh marky outlined so this is
a a reaction to that it's a
necessary step in the evolution of the
court and i'm glad
to i'm proud to co-sponsor all right
everything that that
lifelong swamp creature troll just said
is a lie so first off the republicans
did not pack the court meaning expand
the court did they get justices through
did trump get three
supreme court justices through through
congress yes
he did that is true but they did not
pack the court meaning
expand the court they are now trying to
change the fundamental
shape of what the court is and what was
his logic well 13 is a nice number
that was in essence his logic we have 13
circuits so we should have 13 judges
again do you think they would be doing
this if they weren't
in charge but guys if you don't get it
yet
the progressives are here to destroy
everything from packing courts to get
rid of getting rid of the electoral
college
to making dc estate to bringing in more
illegals like you name it to passing a
green new deal and
cow farts are going to power the country
or whatever it is that she wants
like they're here to destroy everything
and
will anyone stand up will anyone stand
up where are my good wise
liberal friends where are you guys so
many of you who told me no no
if trump is just out of the way we'll be
able to fight them more
but trump is such an aesthetic injury as
my friend gad sad would say
he's so bad he's so uniquely awful and
orange
that if once he's out of the way we'll
be able to fight more well you guys have
all folded pretty quickly right
where are you
you're all gone you're all gone there's
there's basically nobody fighting
there's
there's some conservatives and
libertarians fighting uh but we
we are freaking under assault people and
uh i'm gonna keep fighting i have
nothing better to do i look
at my calendar i have a lot going on but
i had nothing better to do
than save the country so i'm gonna keep
going guys real quick before we get into
the
q a i want to talk to you about start
mail you know free email services like
gmail and yahoo aren't really free
i talk about this all the time you pay
with your privacy and since those
companies have access to
every email you send and receive big
tech can sell your data to the highest
bidder from business plans to medical
records companies can sell
your personal data to target you with
intrusive ads and open you up to
identity theft and phishing attacks
that's why start mail wants to secure
your email and make you feel safe again
start mail keeps your email private
period
every email is encrypted even if the
recipient doesn't use encryption which
means big tech
can't read scan analyze or sell your
personal information ever
start mail also prevents government
agencies from spying on you like in
dragnet operations
with start mail deleted means deleted
when you delete an email it's gone
forever and start mail uses their own
servers not
amazon's which means they can't be put
out of business like parlor
start mail is also backed by the most
stringent privacy laws in the world you
get
unlimited anonymous aliases the feature
this feature protects your main email
address from spam and phishing attacks
so when you're
giving your email to a company but want
to protect your identity start mail can
generate a shareable alias email
so people can't sell your information
and then they can be deleted at any time
here at the reuben report we've been
looking for alternatives to google so
we're excited
by what start mail has to offer i don't
trust big tech and either should you
start securing your email privacy with
start mail sign up today and you'll get
fifty percent off your first year
go to start mail.com
reuben.startmail.com
start with the t mail.com
rubin for fifty percent off your first
year start mail.com ruben and now back
to me oh guys one little
quick technical thing uh we we noticed
in the youtube comments that a bunch of
you saw that our video and audio was a
little out of sync yesterday not if you
watched live
but if you watched after apparently on
youtube there was a little bug some
weird little thing happened
shouldn't happen again we think we have
it under control i can't imagine
youtube would be messing with us no
conspiracies here there are no
conspiracies i want to be very clear
about that
okay uh here we go q a and all of these
of course were submitted
at reubenreport.locals.com morning
and uh i hope to see more you there we
got a great little community
chugging along uh lori says you had
presented a chart in one of your daily
updates in the last week or so that
showed that 73 percent of democrats
trusted the corporate media how in the
world are we ever going to bridge the
gap and work with people if we can't
even get to a place
where we get the same info this is the
question of our time like we could be
frustrated about packing the courts we
could be frustrated about taking out the
electoral college
we could be frustrated that we have a
media that cheers on people burning down
cities
all of those things but what sits above
all of that right like what's here
if all that stuff is here is that the
information layer and if truth is here
let's say truth is the highest thing
well then there's the filters right and
then there's
what happens on the ground and
unfortunately if 73
of democrats so let's say that's roughly
half of america so it's something like
175 million people something like that
if 73 you know three quarters of them
believe the nonsense
that mainstream media is peddling all
the time that is a
whole lot of people right 73
of 175 million people right that's over
100 million people what do you do
with that i don't know what you do with
that this is what i'm trying to figure
out
how can we bridge that divide because
otherwise the more we go into our
silos we're going to be living in
different worlds than people and i
always use the example it's like my
neighbors i don't know what their
political beliefs are i don't care what
their political beliefs are as long as
we're neighborly with each other right
like that's all you want
that's the exchange in a free society
they get to believe what they want i get
to believe what i want
but the problem is if they really start
believing some crazy blue and on
nonsense like
for all i know they believe that brett
kavanaugh was a racist they believed
that the jesse smellet thing wasn't a
hoax
uh they believe all the endless they
believe in the russia hoax and the
ukraine hoax
um you know today it's coming out now
that uh remember a couple months ago
that there was this
report that russian trump knew that
russian what was it that russian
operatives basically were paying
people to kill american soldiers that
turns out to be nonsense
the washington post article from months
ago about trump pressuring the secretary
of state
from georgia to find both like it all
becomes nonsense and what do you do if
you know the people that you meet in
life just believe a completely other set
of things
and by the way that's not for me to sit
here and say that every piece of
information
that i'm getting through the sources
that i basically trust is absolutely
true i do the best that i can and it is
it is my job to try to you know
sort of siphon through that nonsense so
that i can give you guys
something that seems somewhat fair and
in the realm of reality but is it
possible that some of that is skewed too
of course it is right like
and if you're listening to anyone on
youtube or anywhere else that doesn't
tell you that then they're just a
complete liar
so i'll keep doing it but i don't i
don't know like
because in essence what you're saying is
how do you give people the red pill how
do you get them to wake up
and that 73 is an awful lot of people
you know the best you can do
is try to keep talking to people about
these things and i get it it ain't easy
because most likely they're going to
call you a racist and a nazi and tell
you that you listen
to that scary ben shapiro and that evil
stephen crowder and that very handsome
dave rubin but he's still a bad dude
and what do you do with all that we we
just have to fight it in our own little
ways in our own little lives like with
your family
with with your friends and that and of
course what the sucky part of that is
you don't want it all to be political
but in those little moments when you're
in that conversation if you can try to
get them
to understand a little something else
that the police are not just
slaughtering black people and more white
people were shot by police than black
people and
just like a series of other things get
him to read a thomas soul book
if you can't do that get him to watch a
prageru video i recommend why i left the
left for a couple years ago
or so you think you're tolerant that was
pretty good or the bravery deficit those
are the three i did i think they're all
in the top 20 if i'm not mistaken
anywho kyle says are the divisions that
we see
and experiencing stemming from a lack of
difficult challenge for everyone to
rally behind
like world war ii space race etc i think
this is a really interesting question
you know
i always think about this sort of like
like capitalism versus communism you
know i'm a child of the 80s i was born
in 76 so my formative years
were the 80s and it was like in the 80s
1985 rocky versus drago they fought
uh in moscow on christmas day ronald
reagan like
america was something the flag was
something to be proud of
capitalism success building things
making money so that you could live the
life you wanted those were all things
now a certain set of people would call
them greed and blah blah blah but like
we sort of knew it was like oh we're
capitalists we're
we love freedom and choice and
individual rights
versus communism which is government
control of everything
and in some ways we could define
ourselves by what we were against boy
that level of control that the
communists have
we don't want that and this is what we
are whether that has flaws or not
separate issue right um then of course
there's world war ii we know we knew as
americans we were fighting nazism
right and now unfortunately all of the
people that that wish to live freely are
called nazis
usually by people self-proclaimed
democratic socialists who have far more
to do
with the nazis who also were socialists
of germany
uh the space race is another great
example of this right like late
late 60s into the early 70s by the way
if i'm not mistaken we have not set a
man on the moon since 1973 that kind of
makes you wonder
so your question is do we need these
national things
to give us an ethos of pride to give us
something to rally behind to give us
something to connect over
i think yes because the fear is that if
we don't have that for the
reasons that i just talked about in the
previous question first off our
information war will just keep
separating us
but then if we don't have something to
rally around that is something good
the only thing we will rally around is
something bad so you know i was in new
york city
during 9 11 i write about in my book but
my dad worked in midtown he could see
the
the second plane or he saw the second
plane hit my grandma lived in new york
city i had plenty of family and friends
there
i remember what new york city after 9 11
was like and i remember what the country
was like after that we really did come
together in many ways but we don't want
to just come together over bad things
we want to come together over good
things and i fear even like if you
really want to think about it's like
if some other horrific terrorist attack
or
or just unimaginable tragedy happened
would it bring us together
at this point would it i mean it was a
very different world
in 2001 and social media was really not
part of the equation back then i
remember i had a little nokia bar phone
where i could play snake on it like we
didn't have
all of this stuff so like what would
bring us together if maybe maybe even a
tragedy wouldn't do that
so we need something whether that's a
mission to mars
whether whatever that might be i mean i
tend to think that these things are
usually things that are
that are uh you know science based or
sort of future based
uh but it's like look kovit happened
kovid not good did it bring us together
do you think we're more united as a
country
like we were fighting this pandemic
together or has it exacerbated
the differences i would say it probably
has exacerbated them this is a tough one
it's a tough one
uh cheryl says do you believe that the
average conservative can truly make a
difference simply by canceling services
and refusing to buy woke by products
from woe companies
i fear people covet convenience over
sending a message well first off
we all covet convenience over sending a
message right like there's many reasons
at this point
i don't have a real problem with amazon
because they make
you know you can get cheap products
pretty quickly they offer a marketplace
for people to get involved but like do
they have too much power
over our lives and have they done some
pretty shady things related to some of
their vendors
and is there a danger in you know one
company having so much of our consuming
power of course but do i still have
amazon
i do i try nothing on amazon we really
make a point of doing that and like
trying to go to stores which is
even more annoying here in la at the
moment because everything's you know
still closed or
half closed or half locked down or
whatever it is um
i think it's it's just something you can
do
it's something you can do so you can
feel good about your life so whether
that's canceling disney plus because of
what they did to gina carano
or not buying coca-cola which you
shouldn't be drinking that sugary
garbage anyway because you're not happy
what they're saying about the
georgia voting law or whatever it is
like that is at least part of it like
maybe that doesn't get us to critical
mass on the numbers
financially to like have these companies
turn around but i think there are an
awful lot of people that have had it
with all of this stuff and if we at
least
started doing that you know if nothing
else if you couldn't get these companies
to turn around because you don't use
amazon for everything or you don't use
you know you don't just endlessly drink
coca-cola or whatever whatever company
is is peddling some message that you
don't care
to be part of if you just don't take
part in it
i think even if you can't change what
that company can do you can do something
to yourself you can say you know i did
the little thing that i could do in my
life to have a clean conscience over all
of this
and i think that is valuable i i know
when i mean it sounds sort of crazy but
like if i
go to especially now if i go to a
mom-and-pop store or a smaller store
to do something or we order online like
directly from the vendor not through
amazon whatev whatever it might be
i actually feel a little bit better it's
like i'm trying
i'm trying there's a big monster out
there i don't know that i can beat that
big monster
but i can have a little dignity and
self-respect in the process
pool party says in a parallel economy
where conservatives have different
businesses like credit cards
a simple credit check could cut out
someone as a conservative and incur the
wrath of the left
leading to ruin lives how do we defend
against the situation like that
there's been a real theme to these first
three questions here um
yeah it's a big problem and maybe we
just do need
complete parallel economies maybe we do
like and maybe it's happening already
i mean you know for as crazy as it feels
right now the red blue situation and
and how you know obviously someone like
me should probably be in florida
or texas at this point and maybe some of
their
blue leaning people should be in a place
like california
it's like it feels like this is all
wrong but in many ways this is the
system working this is federalism as i
as i always talk about right like
desantis is doing a heck of a job
in florida and is reaping the rewards of
that because everybody
from san francisco is fleeing there i
mean i think i mentioned to you guys i
went to this investors meeting
in december for locals and we'll have
some updates on that
next week for sure it's just a lot of
stuff going on at once
but the amount of people like these were
major money people industry people tech
people that are fleeing
they're literally they're fleeing blue
cities san francisco they're fleeing
blue states california
and they're moving to florida they're
moving specifically to the miami area
but maybe we do need
our own banks our own payment processors
our own tech companies locals.com are
our own food distribution centers our
own educational institutes you know i
just read this morning
that new york state is officially
putting like diversity and inclusion
into the curriculum that's going in
that's going in i actually texted my
brother i said i don't know how long you
can keep the kids
in public school like everyone's going
to have to make some decisions for
themselves
but how do we defend against it if the
irs gets involved well
let's not forget lois lerner under the
obama administration they used the irs
as a political tool
to go after tea party groups we all know
that mainstream media didn't really
cover it
but we all know that they did just that
and this is why you don't want a
government so big that it can basically
take anyone out
todd says watching society degrade to a
victim culture is difficult what keeps
you motivated to continue
building when there is a future that is
uncertain or when future is uncertain
um what choice do i have what choice do
i have like
it i guess there is a certain theme to
what's going on here now the four
questions today like
what what choice do you got like either
if you think something's wrong either
you do something about it or you don't
for some reason i'm doing something
about it and i don't see how i could
even turn around i
had a call this morning actually uh with
someone that's been on the show a couple
times somebody
who i who i highly respect who's really
feeling burnt
by this whole thing and sort of like how
much longer can i
continue to fight what for what i think
is right like as we watch it all kind of
collapse and it's like
what i said was well you don't really
have a choice like i think the choice
has already been made
you know like the choice once you say
this is who i am this is what i believe
this is what i'm gonna fight for well
then
the path the path is sort of written for
you it doesn't mean you know exactly
where you're going to go it doesn't mean
exactly
you know exactly what's going to happen
along that road
but i feel i have nothing better to do
than than fight for what i think is
right that really is it like
maybe there's some other ways that i
could live that would
offer me some more security right like i
suppose i could just
end all of this stuff and like just
disappear
like and i'm not saying that i haven't
ever thought of it i have thought of it
um and by the way when i go whenever
that happens it ain't happening anytime
soon because i am in this fight with you
guys but when that happens when i
disappear one day i'm gone like that
that's it like i will not be like
playing around anymore it'll be like
galt's gulch reuben's gone what happened
to him and as
it stands right now i think kyle kashuv
wants the youtube channel we'll deal
with that at the time
um but uh i think if if you see
well here's a little v for vendetta if
you see what i see
if you feel what i feel well then you
have to do something
nobody is coming to save us we got to
save ourselves man
jackie says is there a coordinated
master plan by certain individuals or
groups to
bring the free america down and if so
who and why man michael there was a
theme
today in these questions there was a
um i guess you guys are feeling what i
feel because that's the theme today is
there a coordinated plan yes
something is going on i don't know what
that machinery is
that is that is just pushing and pushing
and pushing us further and further
and and testing us on any given day and
giving us completely conflicting
messages about lockdowns and kovid
and the economy and saying we're going
to keep moving on the supreme court
and all of like everything what feels
stable to you right now
what feels stable to you i'm not saying
that you know what i try desperately to
do
on this show and communicate to you guys
is that there is hope and there is
always hope of course there is so i
don't do this to be alarmist
but does it feel like some of this is
coordinated somehow that there is
some how i don't know exactly what it is
but it's something like this
there is somehow a coordination between
the democrat
woke progressive machine and big tech to
basically make us
all crazy and make us all hate each
other and fundamentally alter
what the united states is and this this
supreme court thing that's why i'm
saying this is
in many ways this is the one this is
this is what could be the final attack
on our institutions
as they exist as they were founded to be
before the whole thing kind of collapses
so i don't know you know it's like
asking like
like who's in charge of the whole
operation you know like do the
illuminati exist
you know like like is it like who's in
charge i don't know
do you honestly does anyone honestly
think this is all because
joe biden is in charge of course not is
obama
running it from behind and by the way
there is that interview a couple years
ago from obama where he was like oh yeah
the best possible thing for me would be
to run
something from behind and i'd have
somebody else being president i don't
know maybe maybe that's something
but there is an assault on the west
somebody along the way whether it's the
chinese whatever it is figured out boy
the soft underbelly of the west
is that they're free and free people
give up pretty easily
and man we got work to do let's see if
the theme continues here
janelle says can you guys give us an
update on the new some recall
i feel like that story just died recall
supporters had until march 17th in the
deadline
to turn in signatures okay so what
happened was we got the 2.1
million signatures roughly and now it's
being kicked to all the machinery of
california that's verifying the votes
and all that i'm hearing from a lot of
people
that they're not even going to let the
recall happen because they're just going
to basically invalidate a ton of the
votes
and that's how corrupt and evil
california is and we'd sort of
be getting exactly what we deserve my
hope is that it still happens i i'm
talking to some insiders who still
believe it will happen will we get some
decent people to run i heard that
caitlyn jenner is running i would vote
for caitlyn jenner
in a second over gavin newsom again two
months from today is when he's saying we
can open up even though he's also saying
our
rates have dropped and everyone over 16
can get the vaccine it's it's
nothing my suspicion is he thinks two
months from today meaning june 15th
because he has a feeling that the recall
is going to keep moving forward and then
right around
probably beginning of june june 10th
when the recall really
they're about to announce it then it'll
be like oh we're opened up and
everyone's just going to want to get
outside and go to the beach and
and all that stuff but you know if you
want to really know what the negligent
part of this is of course that
is that the mainstream media is not
talking have you seen it on cnn once
other than
when they call it a right-wing
conspiracy or it's fueled by right-wing
crazies
that the governor of the second largest
state in the union is being recalled
they don't cover it so that's one type
of fake news that i lay out and don't
burn this book one
you know people think fake news is just
oh they're lying to you or the headline
doesn't match what's in the
story but another type of fake news is
what they don't show you because they're
intentionally doing that because there
are very few journalists left
they are activists not journalists james
says you mentioned previously that you
have attended pride events in the past
now that pride in the lgbt movement has
morphed into something completely
different
would you attend a pride parade well
first off so i have attended pride
parades
um believe it or not david and i
actually met at a pride parade
i had a radio show at the time so i was
a somewhat public person we had said
where we were going to be
we actually met this is now 12 years ago
or something we've been together for a
long time which by the way after you've
been together for about 12 years
uh that's like 50-something straight
years so we've been together forever
basically
um but um and he was wearing an american
flag actually he was wearing an american
flag uh t-shirt
there's a little little insider info for
you um
you know for those first few years those
first couple years when i was kind of
coming out of the closet and just
accepting reality and being who i was
and all that stuff it did have a meaning
to me to be there because you can't
believe it you go to these parades and
you see all these other people and you
realize oh they're just human beings
and they want to love who they want to
love and you want to love who you want
to love and that's it you know
and then there's all sorts of awful
parts of it too and and i don't even
need to get into that
but after the first two or three years
of it where it had some meaning to me
then i would go sort of and i never
really enjoyed it i never felt that
comfortable there
you know i often say i'm only gay after
10 p.m and uh
i it was just like too in your face and
all of that stuff but i would say
more broadly speaking you know the gays
and the lesbos and the buys you know
and the trans everyone's equal
everyone's treated equally there are no
laws
harming any of those people anymore but
the cops need a certain amount of crime
as chris rock would say and that's why
the lgbtqi movement whatever letter you
want to put in there
it's become in essence it's become
you know a political thing more than
about pride or about just being yourself
so i have really no need to go i haven't
gone to one in years i think when we
moved to west hollywood
which was originally where we lived and
we moved to l.a which is the gayest
place on earth i mean they have rainbow
crosswalks we went to one pride parade
we went out there for a minute and i was
like
you want to go home and watch golden
girls and that's pretty much what we did
so i have no i just it's not important
it's not important to me
and by the way that is the beautiful
thing about equality
you know when you give people equality
true equality which is again what we
have here in the united states
um they don't need the the obsessive
identification of a group identity
because it's like oh but i'm just like
everybody else i'm treated fairly
but the problem is that the leaders of
these things and i'm glad
and the human rights campaign and these
these gay organizations
they can't let go of the fight because
they're non-profits and they want to
nonprofits you're still making money
right people are still paid so they need
that's the cops need a certain amount of
crime like they
need people to believe that they're
coming for the gays and they're coming
for the trans and they're not they're
just
not given emily says given that you and
david hope to have a family one day
would you put your child into the public
school system
or go to a private school slash home
school route
there's a real theme man um
no 100 without question like i can't say
it any crystal clear that i'm going to
say we will never
send our children to public school um
like you just cannot i mean i just told
you that in new york they're now
telling us that the diversity and
inclusion stuff is going into the
schools and we know it's already been
there
um i sense it will be either a charter
school or a private school i think
possibly a home school route you know
there are people fighting back i've had
chris ruffo on the show and corey
d'angelis we just did that episode
uh about a week ago no it was about two
three weeks ago actually time flies
these days
uh about all about schooling and
homeschooling and charter schools and
everything else
but you know i've said this before but
one of my one of the last things that
allowed me to say hey i'm still a lib
guys i'm still a good liberal
was that i believed that there was some
role in
for the government related to public
education and i went to a blue ribbon
high school
i went to a good state school of new
york
suny binghamton state university of new
york uh
you know publicly funded school so i
believed at one time there really was a
role for that but now because
woke-ism is a mind virus that has
infected
all of this stuff it to me it would be
negligent it would be negligent now now
the problem with that is i get a lot of
people don't have money for private
schools or charter schools
but this is why one of the things that
corey dangerous uh
and and the panel talked about a couple
weeks ago was that what you want if
anything
the government should fund students to
figure out where they want to go so you
give flexibility ironically
or not ironically i suppose the
democrats are completely against school
choice so
elizabeth warren who sends her kids to
private schools she doesn't want school
choice
she doesn't they just want to keep
throwing money at public schools because
where
would be a better place to brainwash
them into your socialist vote
progressive
than a public school and then you send
them to free college right bernie would
have sort of the free college you think
they're gonna
you think at bernie's free colleges
they're gonna learn about thomas soul
and about libertarian economics and
about freedom and liberty somehow i
doubt it
ah one more yvonne we're mixing it up
what else
in addition to strawberries is growing
in your garden so we've got a little
rooftop garden where we've got four
planters
uh we're growing a bunch of tomatoes
which really are starting to take off
now that it's warmed up a little bit
strawberries just in the last couple
weeks are exploding i'll
i'll post a picture uh in in the locals
community this afternoon there really we
got some big
red juicy delicious strawberries
cooking uh we're also doing a couple
types of lettuce and some brussels
sprouts
which they're they're nice and hearty
but we're waiting for the big stock
that's what you want out of the brussels
sprout we also got a couple of citrus
plants and some oranges
that kind of stuff um all right
i feel better i feel a little better
than i did when the show started i was
on a couple newsmax shows this morning
and i
then and i was kind of real riled up and
then i wanted to punch somebody and
then i got it out with you guys here
let's all do it together you at home
let's take a breath
it's going to be all right guys we're in
this thing together
part two of my interview with nick
gillespie from reason magazine is up on
youtube right now so you can check that
out the full episode
of course is up totally ad-free at
reubenreport.locals.com
and as i've been teasing tomorrow we're
going to do a panel on policing with
brandon tatum
mike the cop and elijah shaffer have a
great day everybody and remember
if you need to
namaste